[Music]
okay
so we got an 800 and we're gonna play e4
as always please save your questions
until after the game ends and we have a
scandi
okay we have a scandy which we have not
had yet
now the scandi is not a bad opening per
se
but at this level we've talked about the
fact that it's very difficult to play of
course knight c3 is the move developing
with tempo and now black has several um
several retreats he goes queen back to
d8 how do we continue to play what do we
do
what do we do we can develop our knight
but let's occupy the center first by
playing d4 so that he doesn't play e5 or
c5 and goes knight c6
okay well he's attacking our pawn we
could play d5
but we're trying to adhere to basic
principles here so let's play knight f3
and defend the pawn while developing our
knights
now this is a situation where it's time
to
violate some principles that we have
laid out we could
absolutely continue developing but look
at this knight on c6
he's moved to squeen around and about so
many times
that we actually can afford to bend some
of the rules
and really harass him a little bit
because he hasn't developed
any of his central pawns and there is a
very clear drawback of that what can we
do
what can we do in this position ladies
and gentlemen
how do we punish the fact that he hasn't
moved
a single pawn in the center yeah
d5 now can black take on d5 note
we have two defenders and two attackers
which means he cannot take on d well he
does
and see a lot of people just don't count
the defenders and attackers of their
same number of attackers and defenders
and you cannot take the pawn because if
you think about it
the knight is an attacker but as soon as
it takes the pawn it's no longer an
attacker
okay we're off a piece it's a perfect
time to practice
converting an advantage after the game
i'll explain what happens after night
before
so let's develop our bishop and unpin
ourselves
as i talk about many times there's two
ways
a broadly speaking of converting a
material advantage you can trade pieces
or you can use that extra piece
or whatever you have to attack but first
and foremost before we even decide on a
plan we need to complete our development
okay a lot of people
get in trouble because they forget that
even though you might be up a piece
fantastic job but you still need to
complete your development you need to
stick to fundamentals
even though you might be up a piece now
goes bishop c5
how do we play here where do you guys
think that we should position this
bishop
and simultaneously perhaps
follow up on one of these two
methodologies carl marksmanship i
completely agree bishop e3 is a great
move let's
disarm his bishop and we're not against
the trade because we're up a piece
if he takes and again guys please save
your questions until
after the game i promise to get to all
of them
what if he takes on e3 with his bishop
do you guys see
on the basis of our discussion of the
two methodologies of converting a
material advantage
what should we take with riemann thinks
we should take with the knight
so what's the case for taking with the
knight exactly yeah
everybody's on the same page we force
the queen trade essentially
because we're simultaneously attacking
the okay so he's just like
he's counter-attacking our knight so in
what order should we do things here what
should we do
like in what order should we do and what
is it that we should even do
and clutch too i guess your question
will be answered
so what do we do let's let's treat
queens first let's get rid of this trade
first let's trade queens although we
don't have to do that we could have
taken on g4 first but i'm trying to be
as methodical as possible then we take
knight takes g4 he has to take our
knight
boom we've traded queens we've won upon
we're up a full piece
and it's clear that we have now chosen
the second method which is to trade as
many pieces as possible without
ruining any part of our advantage or our
position so
in the spirit of that that method what
do we do
how does white continue here we can play
this move very safely
rook t1 is good but why don't we first
take the knight we have a chance for
another trade
does it ruin our position or make a
concession nope to the contrary
it ruins his pawn structure now let's go
rookie to d1
trying to initiate a rogue trade now in
such positions and we've talked about
this before and he's doing our bidding
for us
it's a very good idea to invest a single
tempo
and make what kind of move let's move
the night away and attack his pawn what
kind of move
is a really good idea in such positions
to take care of our future self
flight square makes space for the king
we can do that in many different ways we
don't have to always play only h3
we can already play f3 we can move the
king out okay we don't have to do all
that but first
let's take the free pawn and i'm not
saying we need to do that immediately
okay so this is a great example of
choosing how to make loft
what does our opponent want and how do
we prevent it
and actually i'll give you guys a hint
we don't even need to make luft
we don't even need to make loft we can
kill all of the birds with one stone
by going to e this is a move you need to
play very carefully right
if it weren't for the pin he would
checkmate us if we didn't have this move
i would actually play king f1
in order to simultaneously guard against
the threat of rookie two again
every single move guys you're trying to
accomplish as much as possible
so it's and now i'm just gonna take the
pawn and we're gonna win but it
essentially when you have an idea do not
play the first move
that accomplishes that idea try to find
the best way of accomplishing that
so what do we do how do we win a
position like this some people struggle
with this
what's going to be the plan the first
thing in such positions
my recommendation bring the king up
first bring the king out
then either promote upon
or distract his king and promote a pun
i'm going to talk a little bit about how
to win such positions
okay so this candy right now the main
line in the scandi is queen a5 that's
the traditional mainland queen d8 is a
move
an entire book has been written about
this now he goes knight c6 which is
already the first mistake
and the first critical moment occurs
here obviously everybody's wondering
what the hell do we do
if knight before happens
um what do we do uh yeah i'll talk about
that kasparov i actually missed that
move but
i think we have stuff we can do there's
a couple of things that we can do here
right
um i like to move bishop to c4 to defend
the pawn and then we can excommunicate
that knight by playing a3
you guys might be but wait a minute he
goes bishop f5 this is so annoying he's
attacking the pawn
at this point and this is a slightly
higher level piece of advice we're
already at 800.
you have to distinguish between activity
and pseudo activity pseudo activity
is sort of a position which looks really
really unpleasant but in reality
it's all an illusion you can easily
defend whatever your opponent is
attacking and then push
all of his pieces away in one fell swoop
he is attacking c2 let's defend c2 by
playing bishop b3 or even knight d4
although i don't really like the fact
that this
intercepts our protection of the pawn
then we're going to play a3
and we're going to easily get rid of
this bishop by playing knight t4
on the other hand black is a very very
hard time getting his pieces out because
e6 always runs into d takes e6
i actually like knight d4 the more i
look at it we can even sacrifice this
pawn
for rapid development good job proper in
fact if he takes the pawn
because he's so undeveloped because his
king is so locked in you need to be
looking for tactics
white has a devastating two move tactic
that wins the game could somebody spot
it please look at his king it has no
squares
yep riemann b should be five this would
be checkmate we're not for c6 now we go
knight takes c6
very straightforward takes takes he's
got to give up the entire
literal army i mean not only does he
give up his queen but he gives up his
knight
and his rook and that is not a
coincidence when you're this
underdeveloped that is literally just
what happens
uh when you try to grab pawns rather
than work
more on your development that's kind of
terrifying indeed
um that's crazy so that's what would
have happened had he played knight
before now the funny thing here guys
is that as kasparov points out i
actually had
missed the move e4 and what is the idea
of the movie for the idea is if we move
the knight back we'll look at this
knight on d5 it's protected only by the
queen
so the queen is what we call overloaded
it protects two pieces at the same time
and it cannot keep its protection open
for very long and black wins back to
peace
so how do we deal and this is i would
say advanced right we're getting into
advanced tactical territory
i'm going to try to make this as clear
as possible
how do we deal with a situation like
this
well we need to reason very very
methodically
the first thing that we need to ask
ourselves is can we move the knights
and bishop there's probably a couple of
good moves but i think
i see one way to solve the problems can
we move the knight
and simultaneously attack
bishop no actually that doesn't work so
is there a way to move the knight inside
the bishop at the same time
could somebody tell me that and and
defend the bishop at the same time yeah
knight d4
but a lot of people would blitz this
move out immediately think okay great so
it takes takes
our queen is no longer overloaded but
the problem is we leave the d5
knight undefended and now if we take the
bishop then black takes our knight and
again black has recovered
the piece so that doesn't work we need
to look for alternate arrangements
alternate solutions
and kasparov indicates one so what we
need to do here is ask ourselves
okay so we know that we're probably
losing a piece
let's think about it another way does e4
make any weaknesses in his position does
it allow any moves
that were not possible before he played
e4 now knight g5 i'm not sure what's
attracting people about this guys
because this is exactly the same thing
as
moving the knight back to e1 you lose a
piece right that's exactly what i talked
about
so the movie forward is it creating any
weaknesses does it allow any moves
that would not have been possible with
the pawn on e5 anything that you guys
can spot
particularly noting that the knight on
d5 is super active beautiful
bishop f4 now we're attacking c7 and
this
is a big deal if black takes we take on
c7
and i'm gonna say that this is a little
bit complicated because after king e7
we have to be extremely careful if we
take the if we just gobble up the rook
mindlessly then he plays f takes c2
it's a fork we have to trade queens the
knight might not be getting out
there's absolutely no need for these
shenanigans
this is why intermediate moves are so
important do not
rush to make a move such as knight takes
eight ask yourself if there isn't
something you can do first
in order to eliminate all of these
annoying nasty threats
and it turns out if you think in that
direction you know you quickly find that
you can take the pawn
with what with what can you take the
pawn by the way this does not win a
queen
because of f6 always remember there
might be a way to block your check
think very carefully guys every tempo is
important you actually take the pawn of
the pawn
you take the pawn with the pawn why why
do you take with the pawn
you could take with the bishop that's
also good you're completely winning here
but from a tactical perspective he would
take with a pun
whoa vladimir bellows raiding with the
party of 44. thank you so much
grandmaster
uh valois a good friend of mine thank
you so much
uh new streamer i'll give him a follow
because
we are attacking simultaneously the
bishop we're attacking both the bishop
and the rook
whereas if we take with the bishop
aren't we also attacking a bishop from
the rook well it's not that simple guys
because now and and this also works just
because we're attacking the king but
from a tactical perspective
he takes back and we have to attend to
these threats
if we take with the pawn he's got to
attend to both the bishop and the rook
and he's simply not able to do that
simultaneously
so how do we quantify this into a
principle
the principle that i would argue here is
that if if there is a peace
an opponent's piece that's hanging and
we're thinking about making an
intermediate move
it's important to try to make that move
with tempo so that he can't solve the
problem of the initial piece
so what can we say about this principle
i hope i hope this makes sense to
everybody so the movie 4 would have been
very unpleasant
but what's the lesson here the lesson is
that when we're in a situation like this
you're always looking for drawbacks even
when things are not going well okay he's
attacking two pieces
when you can't find a direct solution
you'll look for the drawback of your
opponent's move and that can awaken you
to moves that otherwise you just
wouldn't have seen because you're too
panicked
okay um any other questions yeah bishop
h3 the line goes on
i want to pause there in that line
because it gets really complicated and
we're not quite at that level yet
okay um
any other question so tempo just means
literally it is italian for time well
it's managed for time
a tempo is just like a move or
it's how do i even define it it's a
that's actually a good question how do
we define tempo it's it's a single move
i guess
right it's the temporal value of a move
okay so consider the difference between
money and a dollar okay money is the
concept itself money is time
whereas a dollar is a single unit of it
a tempo is the single chess
unit right so it's like a single move
when you gain a tempo
you gain a move what does it mean to
gain a tempo gain attempt
means let's say you're attacking your
opponent's piece your opponent has to
move that piece
and therefore he gives you one more move
not the best definition but i think that
gives you a good sense of it
okay um so it's something that your
opponent has to attend to which gives
you
which gives you a new move um which
gives you an extra move rather
not quite my tempo but it could also
just mean
um you know it could mean that in a more
general sense i don't want to get
into this too much because i'm going to
try to explain this through the moves
themselves
continuing the game he blunders a piece
okay so we play bishop e3 and at this
point how do we decide between these two
moves well we decide between these two
moves because we see
that if we take with a knight we
basically force a queen trade we
actually do not
totally force a queen trade he can keep
he can keep the queens on the board how
how can black keep the queens on the
board and save his bishop
could somebody please explain to him how
to to keep uh queen series one way
but but the best is to play bishop back
to d7 if you play queen c8
then white takes on g4 alarm bells
ringing boom boom boom what do we do now
what do we do now
as soon as we see an x-ray this is a
standard
garden variety x-ray situation and we
exploit that x-ray by moving the night
out with
maximal the maximal damage black knight
takes c5 very good
and that's it then we're gonna take the
knight we're up a piece we have the e
file open this is now knight takes c5
wins the tempo right we attack the queen
he has to attend to that queen
giving us another move it's basically
kind of like we're playing two moves in
a row
obviously we're not but his move is kind
of empty because he just has to move his
queen
okay um so bishop d7 would have kept the
queens on the board
but this is a huge concession it makes
his pieces very passive
one option here is to centralize our
queen and then attack d5 there's many
ways to play this but anyways
don't want to delve too deeply here
takes the queen takes the bishop
fakes bishop c6 literally just trading
all the pieces trading
rooks as well centralizing the knight
taking
now here just very very quickly had
bukti not been possible let's ace king
would have been on g7
the move king f1 i want this to make
sense to everybody why is this better
than h3 because h3 allows
him to infiltrate with rookie 2. this is
not the end of the world we can drop our
knight back and attack the rook force it
back but
again h3 is the most careful move
because it actually kills three birds
with one stone
it brings the king closer to the center
which is something you want to do in the
end game
it stops rookie 2 and it also prevents
the backrank checkmate hey lily
good to see you so this is the kind of
multi-purpose move that you want to make
many times throughout the game
and at the end the game was over
immediately king f1
how do we win a position like this well
the first thing i'd do is i'd centralize
the king
and it depends where or black at some
point you would start playing a4
and there's two fundamental ways of
winning a position like this i mean even
without the knight
kind of the same thing right bring the
knife back you can directly promote
the pawn using your resources to promote
the spawn
you can also use the spawn as a decoy
this is what i would probably end up
doing
trying to distract his king and then in
the time that his king spends attending
to the pawn
you then come around and take all of
these pawns and promote your pawns
so this is how this would look right you
would just come around and vacuum up
these pawns
and um if you wanted to actually just
promote the pawn without going around
then you would literally stick to the
queen side and you would use the other
pawn to prepare a5
and etcetera etcetera i don't want to
delve too deeply into this i think most
people can comfortably
realize an advantage like this art
sastrom
alright so he goes g3 well in such
situations we already know the rule of
thumb
we simply occupy the center again this
is one of those openings where we don't
really need to overthink things
let's just develop our pieces again and
again and again we see this hammered
homie goes d4
now we've already been in this situation
where we need to decide between
two things what are we deciding here
what is black's main decision
what is black's main decision
whether to do what closed
or open or push so what do you guys
think should we close the position here
we can actually do either i mean either
is good
but i want to give you guys some more
practice closing the position up i want
to show because a lot of people
and i don't want to put words in
anyone's mouth um
but a lot of people just
don't have that intuition about playing
in closed positions we had one of them
before
in this speed run which is more like a
slow run but that's why i called it a
speed run just
a little bit of a troll uh it is a slow
run
but i wanna reinforce these concept now
he plays this correctly you go c4
remember guys from the last time
you want to attack the base of the pawn
chain so how do we react here we don't
really take the pawn because that would
make our center collapse
we instead protect the pawn with another
pawn going c6 building what's called a
pawn chain
he's go he goes queen c2 which is a bit
of an aimless move
and uh this allows us simply to continue
developing which we are going to do
by bringing our bishop out well he go so
he's just doing all this stuff that's
that's
you know we don't want to dismiss it we
don't want to ignore it
but we just want to continue developing
okay we basically do ignore it
he's moving his pawns while we're
developing our pieces
but let's try to decide now how we will
continue our development where do you
guys think that we should put this
bishop
where does this bishop on c8 belong also
bearing in mind what he just did he
played h4
what is the consequence of the move h4
the consequence is that he can no longer
play
h3 which means we can slam this bishop
onto a really weak square
it's kind of like an outpost for the
bishop he continues to expand
now here's the thing guys and this is i
know going to be hard to swallow
but there comes a time when he's so
undeveloped
so undeveloped that we actually need to
open up the center
even if that means opening up
and destroying our own pawn chain okay
there are situations that are it's so
important to open the center
that it's even worth sacrificing the
integrity of the pawn chain
to open up that center because what you
guys are going to notice and i will talk
about this
in depth after the game there
chess is a game where you can't make an
omelet without breaking some eggs
and here because he's on developed he's
going to pay the price for it even
though we don't have
um a pawn chain he's made an even worse
move he's given up the only piece
that defends all of the weak light
squares around his king
so it's going to be very important to
adhere to two principles thank you so
much and chris
one is going to be to play actively to
play with tempo
the other is going to be to keep our
eyes on the press keep opening up the
center when possible
but to protect all our pawns so can we
defend this bishop of tempo
to answer our first question can we
defend this bishop
with gain of tempo we can but daniel
aren't you moving upon in front of the
king well i addressed this earlier right
yes we are but look at white's pieces
all of his pieces are on his starting
square and he thinks he's a genie he
went upon
i don't care let him take this pawn
we're going to keep opening stuff up and
ripping apart
the center and the queen's head how else
do we open up the position
any other pawn breakthroughs remember f4
is not working
are there other pawn breakthroughs we
could execute
are there any yeah let's go a5 let's
open up that queen side too
the more we open up the harder it's
going to be for him
to uh protect his pieces and his weak
pawns
thank you oh look at that file that's a
juicy file
can we occupy that file with one of our
pieces
that beautiful c file let's occupy that
file how can we do that
and i know that i'm getting low on time
but don't worry if i get down to 30
seconds i will take over
yeah defending attacking the bishop now
do you guys remember when he played h4
a move like h4 you need to be very
attentive to because it creates
a lot of weaknesses in particular
you guys see this car what can we do
with the g3 pawn
what can we do with that g3 pawn oh
absolutely
absolutely let's take that pawn
absolutely because what's gonna happen
is that he's so undeveloped
as soon as we open up the position piece
is a very small price to pay and i'm i'm
how do you know that well i know that
intuitively i'll explain a little bit
more of the thought process
i'll explain a little bit more of the
thought process after the game
but by and large a lot of people should
see this right you can see how
overwhelmingly
better developed we are and all that
remains after he plays king f1 is to
open up the position a little bit more
and he's just going to collapse so what
do we do after king f1
how do we continue opening up the
position a certain move that used to be
impossible
is now possible yep bingo dr lono
get ready because we are about to crush
knight f3 how do we proceed okay he's
just sort of collapsing he's trying to
throw water onto the fire
um what do we do what do we take what do
we take and we can take several
different things
um we can take the knight or we can take
the pawn both moves are fine
um but what do we do first well let's
let's take the knight first okay because
um we attack the rook and if he's
offering us that material back let's
just deal with that so we don't have to
worry about it
and now after king g1 okay he goes king
u1 so what do we do now
and this speaks to the concept of
flexibility right
we don't want to pre-move ftxd3 he's
offered us a rook
we're just taking a rook and we're still
attacking this game is over
notice that i still haven't taken i
finally take on e3
and how do we actually win the game
using
one of the main principles we have
discussed which is that when you're up
so much material
what you often want to do is just bring
all of the rest of the pieces into the
game
that's going to make it so much easier
to
actually deliver the checkmate rather
than hunting for the mate
with very few pieces rook f3 is fine but
let's practice that art
of bringing pieces in i know this isn't
the best move
i know i have 24 seconds left don't
worry i'll win
but i still want everybody to practice
always
bringing pieces in when you get obsessed
with that you find
that this allows you to win the game in
a far easier manner after king c4 how do
we win
his queen i want to hear a move before i
make a move i want to hear someone say
the move
come on guys queen e 2
bingo you say z got it and now i can
actually win
rook f5 if he goes d5 i take it
boom boom now i'm up a queen and then
i'm gonna take his bishop and the game
is over red rover and those of you who
are holding your breasts do not because
i am experienced
but don't try this at home check and
where is the mate
where is the mate okay i'm giving it
away of course
you see how easy it was after i brought
my pieces and i'm sorry for the time
scramble at the end
this guy was good he was resilient he
was not bad at all and you can see that
these guys are resisting a little bit
better
okay now let's unpack this game so
here if you did not want to close up the
center you could also play the move
knight c6
which would be entirely possible
entirely doable
um but i want to close up the center
because i want to show you guys
a little bit more how to play with the
center being close so he goes queen cc
and he starts playing all these pawn
moves
this is what people often do he just
doesn't know what what he's doing
i mean he does not know what the plan is
bishop g4
and this is the key moment in the entire
game you might be asking why was there
such a necessity to open up the center
well the thing is
if we continue developing then he kind
of justifies
you know what he's just done how can he
now proceed on the queen side
and close things up and then start
attacking actually
and and this is why partially yep this
is partially why now he can start
developing maybe he wouldn't have but
this is partially why it's so hard to
play with closed positions
because not only do you have to handle
the intricacies of the closed position
itself but you sometimes have to
recognize the moment when to open the
position up
okay that's why we took because none of
his pieces are developed
he should have taken the c4 pawn and now
we could have ripped the position open
further by playing a5
a move that we played later on in the
game he gets into big trouble here
because he cannot keep things closed
for very much longer okay
how did i know that that's the right
time to attack well i realized that if i
gave him one more move
he would have played c5 that wouldn't
have been terrible
but i did not want to give them give him
that opportunity again
okay um so that's basically the
intuitive
backdrop behind dtx4 now here
i could have not allowed queen e6 could
have gone queen d7
okay um and that would have been
perfectly fine i didn't have to play
with temple but i wanted to emphasize
that sometimes it's very important to
play with temp i also wanted to
emphasize
that sometimes pawns are not important
and this is one of those situations
okay this is one of those situations
yes he's up upon look at this his queen
is the only piece that's developed all
of his other pieces are underdeveloped
are undeveloped which means two things
first of all we need to keep opening up
the position second thing we have to
operate with a sense of urgency
what happens if we don't operate with a
sense of urgency
is that with every piece that he
develops he minimizes our initiative
he minimizes our advantage because our
advantage is dynamic
which means it can evaporate at any
moment if he develops two or three
pieces well guess what
his position is still riddled with holes
but it's not nearly as bad as it would
be here
so that is why we play a5 okay he goes
b5 opens the c file
and now we go queen c7 dynamic and
static are opposites
attacking the bishop and also eyeing
that g3 pawn
how did i know to eye that g3 bundle as
i said
the moment he played h4 i made a mental
note on my mental database of
observations
look at this pawn always look at this
pawn as soon as i play queen c7
he sacrifices now on the table this is
the importance of observation
i've talked about this since the very
first game of the speedrun chess
is not only about looking for moves you
know about
calculating it's also about observing
making observations just like in the
scientific method
okay the more you observe the more you
note down
the more informed and the deeper your
ideas eventually become
and it's not rocket science to make an
observation like this one
okay so i noted that pawn and this is
when i remembered it
because it's easier now for me after so
many years
of experience to keep these observations
uh in in my mind
um i get it until contact with the pawns
exactly
knight d2 bishop takes g3 okay so this
sacrifice should now make a lot of sense
to everybody
because we have such an overwhelming
number of pieces already in the attack
now we're trying to open up that f file
now in this position
and i don't think i'm doing scc i did do
the junior sec
what would happen if white played e4
and this is the move that would cause a
lot of people concerned because it looks
like he keeps the file closed
but again we need to be very flexible we
need to take stock of all of our
attacking pieces and see which ones
can now participate directly in the
attack
and this mover this move ends the game
because it threatens essentially
checkmate
and if he takes well then we open up
that file so this literally just
walls close in around white's gang the
game is over instead he won knight f3
trying to
throw his body between me and the king
but
it doesn't matter and here i just decide
to take all of his pieces now here
a lot of people yeah why not rook f3
kind of ladder checkmate he has to cover
with this queen moving the queen
again i'm not saying this isn't the best
move it probably is i'm trying to
emphasize
the general concept of bringing the
pieces in very patiently
so that then the wind becomes a little
bit easier by the way at the very end
this is a very simple tactic i'm seeing
the king is defending the queen it's
overloading
you are distracting i guess also decoy
you're distracting the king from the
defense of the pawn
it's a very very simple mechanism that
most people should see intuitively but i
will point out a piece of advice here
which is that um the two worst defenders
and listen closely because i'm gonna
make a couple qualifications here the
two worst defenders of a piece
are the king and the queen when the king
or the queen
defending peace that piece is generally
very very vulnerable
why if they it that's counterintuitive
in the queen sense because you might
think the queen is the best defender but
it's the worst defender
because the moment a queen is attacked
it has to move the moment a knight is
attacked by another night sometimes you
couldn't reinforce that knight
but when a queen is attacked it
essentially has to move and abandon
whatever piece it's defending
and the same exact thing goes for the
king the king by law
by the laws of chess has to move when it
is attacked
that is czech and so it comes above
everything else the king is a very
selfish peace
so it must abandon whatever piece it's
protecting
you guys see what i'm saying so just
keep that in your mind any questions
before we move on to perhaps the final
uh or the penultimate game of the speedo
i appreciate everybody's support and all
the subs and everybody just
participating it's awesome and uh thank
you for also respecting my wishes
in terms of politics uh drake speaking
of subs and support drake
th95 with two months appreciate it
thank you so much all right fantastic
let's move on i guess
okay 810 nishant mundus and here we're
actually going to play
an opening other than what we've been
playing so far well
he's done that for us so he's played d4
and let's play d5 let's play it
classically conventionally goes a3 okay
so this is already a bad move
which basically means we can develop and
he's giving us a lot of time
now the movie six would not be actually
optimal what would be the
optimal scheme of development here and
the way to understand that
is to realize what the drawback is of
the movie 6. if you guys know what the
drawback is
you know that you want to first develop
the bishop outside the pawn chain
and then play e6 and prepare the
development of the other bishop
okay so he's making moves with the same
piece he seems like he's intimidating us
let's ignore him let's just keep
developing and you guys will see quickly
that this okay well this is just
ridiculous
he has absolutely no pieces to exploit
this
you know slight weakening of our king
expected lemon thank you for the five
months
how do we continue how do we continue
what do we do how do we actually
coordinate our forces justin
thank you let's castle let's finish
castling now in such situations
as yazi and others are pointing out it's
a very good idea to ask the bishop okay
so he does our bidding force
h6 is a great idea sometimes because if
bishop h4 we would
later be able to play g5 should we need
to get rid of the pin
now let's continue what's called
castling by hand
that would be playing rook fate now
playing king
g8 and that's as simple as that we just
move our king
and we've essentially castled without
actually castling do we care about the
double pawns we do not because he's
helping us straight pieces
what do you notice now about this
position what do you guys notice
um and and what observations can we make
that might motivate us to decide
between trying to trade pieces and
trying to attack
now we've got the open f file not only
do we have the open file we have access
to the semi-open g-file with the king
can we exploit the f2 pawn if we didn't
have the bishop here it would be made
but it actually turns out and i'll give
you guys a little bit of it and it's
very hard actually to exploit that
because
and i've mentioned this before be very
careful
when you're considering a move like
bishop d3 because he takes with the
queen and he simultaneously vacates
the d1 square for the knight bishop
takes c2 he takes with the queen of
defense f2 the advice
specifically that i have to share is
when you're considering
a discovery specifically a discovery
make sure
that he cannot take the piece that
delivers the discovery and
simultaneously
defend the pawn of the square that
you're trying to target
that is one of the most common sources
of mistakes instead of this i'm gonna go
queen g6
and i'm going to redirect my attack on
this incredibly weak g2 square
but can't he castle what he can but this
walks right into a very very typical
stock tactical pattern
you can take this but let's keep our
eyes on the prize there's a far greater
prize which is of course
the king we go bishop h3 we force him to
go g3
we're going to win another exchange and
we are going to end up simply
up a full rook yes we don't no longer
have an immediate attack
but well never mind i guess we do have
an immediate attack
yeah he's not exactly in the best of
form it seems in this game
but again uh he also yeah well that okay
well let's just end the game here with
the queen takes you two
yeah um in any case just i guess this
will be a quick one
uh every it should make sense to
everybody
that the movie six is sub-optimal
because it blocks the bishop
but those of you who know the queen's
gambit know that black often plays e6
and
i mean the opening not the show so you
might be like
well daniel just told me queen's gambit
is bad
i see hikaru and others playing the
queen's game but is the queen's gamut
then bad
it's not bad the queen's gamut is one of
the most reputable one of the most solid
openings in existence
but when you're playing black you
sometimes have to play an opening that
contains a drawback
almost every opening has drawbacks
particularly with black
and you could play bishop f5 here that's
called the baltic opening
but the drawback of that is that he can
take on d5 and essentially destroy black
center
okay so just wanted to make clear the
king's queen's gamut is not terrible
it's an incredibly good opening uh but
given the opportunity
we can basically play the queen's gamut
on steroids if you play c4 we play e6
and our bishop is outside the pawn chain
thank you
zero eleven vlad 110 for the twitch
prime let's keep that hype train going
this is awesome um thank you guys so
much
okay so the rest was very
straightforward now what would we have
done
what would we have done and jelly asks a
great question
why the hell not bishop g4 the move
bishop g4 might have walked into knight
e5
um and you're pressuring this bishop
that's really the only reason this is
not even bad we can now bring the bishop
back to f5
but there's really no reason to uh to
allow this move curious jim banzu
with five gifted tier one subs to the
community thank you so much
incredible stuff going on tuscinator
carso triple n
griller kingkiller88 and raslos
uh receiving the subscriptions thank you
so much carrie as always
so supportive okay so what would we have
done had he simply and one
nd7 gifting a sub to shival and this is
incredible
how would we play in a position like
this after
castling could somebody explain to me
a good plan in this position yeah i'll
all
hundred bits corgis are cute thank you
tortugas grande
and what would be the plan here yeah so
you guys really are aware of the ideas
you would go c5 to undermine
the d4 square which brings me to a
detour
i myself play an opening called the job
of london yaziz five holy smokes
dpp 67 momentum kyle's speaking of
momentum kyle motto missy
marvin and the hound of cs the move
knight is knight c3
move knight c3 it's not the same as
going e4 and knight f3 because the moon
knight c3
blocks his ability to either go c3 to
protect upon or c4 to contest black
spawn that's why
this is not a standard move i still play
it
for a you know other reasons that i
won't get into right now
but that's the reason why knight c3 is
often frowned upon
in queens pawn openings precisely for
the reason on full display here
the d4 pawn is now under significantly
more pressure than it would have been if
light would have been able to play c3
after he castles we can go knight pd7
and try to get this knight
out of e5 that's why it's only strong
piece if we can get this knight out of
v5 we have fantastic coordination
between our pieces
we have the ability to attack on the
king side and the ability to pressure
the queen side perhaps by bringing the
rook to c8
okay that was a lot um i hope that
that makes sense to everybody any last
questions after he took
i really don't have to get into this we
just castled by hand
and played queen g6 just to show the
move bishop takes c2
very very common blunder to repeat that
piece of advice when you are looking for
a discovered attack
or a discover check or discovered
whatever make sure
that you are not let's say sacrificing a
piece and allowing your opponent to
recapture it
and simultaneously defend whatever
square or pawn or piece
you are trying to discover the attack on
okay i hope that that makes sense a
little bit of clunky wording i'll work
on it but
i think that the gist of it makes it
what about yeah bishop h3 would be
possible
uh and perhaps he could castle here and
then we could play queen g6 so we could
do the same transposed
that would be acceptable bishop e4 would
be acceptable would bishop d3 be
acceptable according to the application
of our device
would this move be acceptable because he
can't take this way this way
but what could white do here it would
not
why not why wouldn't this be acceptable
queen takes d3 and unfortunately he's
opened up this d1 and black is still
attacking black is still much better
there's really no no point here now
bishop b4 he would castle
after queen g6 he could play f3 we don't
have the same thing we did in the game
unfortunately the bishop has to move we
could take c2 we're up a pawn
but we're not up in exchange right with
queen g6 and bishop h3 we win
an entire exchange and we're up an
entire rook given that we were up a
piece already
okay let's proceed if everybody's ready
on to the next game